nous sommes humains nous sommes
supérieurs parce que nous avons une
conscience de ce qui est bien de ce qui
est mal
non je pense que je ne signerai pas le
référendum les droits des animaux
en fait parce qu'il met sous le vocable
de bien-être animal des choses qui à mon
avis n'ont rien à voir entre et d'un
côté des mesures qui visent à améliorer
la condition des animaux d'élevage mais
à côté de ça on a des mesures qui
interroge un peu plus sur par exemple
l'interdiction des spectacles de cirque
qui sont des mesures qui concerne moi la
question du bien-être des animaux mais
la dila plutôt la dignité des animaux
ces deux questions de la vie n'ont rien
à voir effet de les mêler ensemble dans
un seul référendum ça entretient une
confusion entre un combat qui à mon avis
est très jeu est une cause plus
idéologique qui serait en fait la cause
antispécistes qui consiste en fait à
vouloir dire que les droits des animaux
doivent progressivement s'aligner sur
les droits humains dans ces cas là à
quel type de personnalité et ce qu'ils
auraient ce qu'ils auraient des droits
comparables au nôtre et ce qu'ils
auraient le droit de vote par exemple
etc
il ya un livre très connu qui est très
célèbre dans la mouvance antispécistes
qui s'appelle zoos police qui propose
une politique adaptée aux animaux pour
mieux prendre en compte leurs intérêts
et qui notamment propose un certain
nombre de mesures notamment qu'une école
pour les chiens et les chats les animaux
de compagnie en fait qui tendrait à
discipliner l'animal pour lui inculquer
notre façon d'être nous sommes humains
nous sommes supérieurs parce que nous
avons une conscience de ce qu'il vient
de ce qui est mal que nous sommes
capables de les dictées de faire
respecter cela avec la loi et en fait
petit à petit ce qui est à craindre
c'est qu'on finisse par ne plus être
capable de penser ce qui nous sépare des
animaux ce qui est de l'ordre encore une
fois de la culture de la vie morale de
la vie intérieure de la vie spirituelle
qui sont à n'en pas douter le propre de
l'homme et que les animaux eux n'ont pas